president joe biden white house press
secretary jen sackey fib about the
administration's coveted plans but the
media cover for them anyway
leftist commentators push for more media
sycophancy and norm breaking
and trump prepares for a senate
impeachment trial i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben i mean look here's the reality i've
been talking about expressvpn on my show
for months why have you not gotten a vpn
yet ladies and gents i will tell you
this there has never been a more
important time to protect
your digital rights that's why i and
thousands of my patriotic listeners
choose to secure our online data by
using expressvpn
did you believe that a vpn isn't for you
because you can use the internet just
fine with that one
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every site
you're visiting are you confused about
how it works well expressvpn is an app
for computers and smartphones that
encrypts your network data
and reroutes it through a secure server
that means you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked do you think the vpns are
complex and only for tech experts
take it from me they are not with
expressvpn you launch the app you tap
just one button to protect yourself it
really is
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they are
rated number one by cnet and wired
they stand for my values now is the time
for you to take a stance take back your
privacy right now
at expressvpn.com get three extra months
for free
on a one-year package again that's p r e
s s vpn dot com slash pen to get three
extra months for free
visit expressvpn.com ben right now it's
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so it is the new day
the dawn has come the clouds have parted
and the rays of light
shine down because joe biden is
president of the united states
and never ever ever will we be lied to
again you know
all that donald trump did for years on
end was lied to us all of his press
secretaries lied to us
kaylee mcinenneny must be barred from
all
human contact we have to put sarah
huckabee sanders in solitary confinement
we have to find sean spicer wherever he
is we have to rest him from the set of
dancing with the stars and bar
him from polite human society but now
now
we have the greatest and most honest of
all of the humans
so many honest humans in the biden
administration it's not that joe biden
is a corrupt old politician he's been in
washington dc since he was 30 years old
and it's not that jen sackey
is an actual overt liar who lied
routinely for a living while she was
with the obama administration no
these are the adults in the room so much
adulthood happening in fact
this is what cnn's dana basha said right
that anyone who has a connection to
reality knows the adults are back in
washington
and that means that we can all just
sleep on this right we can go to sleep
again
because let's let's be real now we can
sleep securely knowing
that when the call comes in the middle
of the night only the greatest wisest
and most honest of human beings will be
occupying the white house here is dana
bash
journalism all over the place about the
wonderful innate honesty and decency of
all the people who are empowered now
it's just amazing here's dana bash
objective journalism
if you take what you just saw and heard
in totality
anybody who has any um connection to
reality
about what is going on around them
should have watched that
and said the adults are back in the room
that is that is what uh
the kind of vibe was that president
biden was clearly trying to get out
there
and it made it easier because he has a
plan that would be uh brianna keeler who
is sitting there going hmm
yes wow yes
so much journalism happening on cnn they
are the objective journalists and you
know what
the white house this white house the
biden white house they hold themselves
to that higher standard in fact jen
sackey again a person who lied routinely
to the media while she was
at the state department under barack
obama now she says we're bringing
transparency back
it's like justin timberlake but with
politics here she is explaining how
wonderful transparency will be
under the biden administration and it's
also being straight
and transparent straightforward and
trans transparent and you know there's
no better example than that
uh than covet 19 and our efforts to get
the pandemic under control
there are going to be days where people
are not going to be hearing what they
want to hear
where the data is going to be concerning
and troubling but
we want to bring transparency back and
uh then so
so we're just going to try to deliver on
that in the briefing room but really the
job the back and forth is the job
wow the back and forth is the job brook
baldwin saying hmm
yes all the way through very solid stuff
there okay so
just how honest and transparent were
they on the first day the very first day
were they super honest were they super
transparent
were they just absolutely clear with the
american public well let's take it from
the top so
joe biden has a plan to stop covet in
fact he tweeted out that he wasn't gonna
stop the economy
he wasn't gonna stop your life he was
going to stop the virus his plan for
stopping virus wait for it
wait for it now wait for it wear a mask
boom
done amazing not as though mask wearing
has been tried all over europe
and has generally not stopped the spread
of the virus not as though there's been
a mask mandate in place in l.a like this
whole time and la is just getting
walloped right now
if joe biden says wear a mask you know
the virus will just die
that's what will happen not only did joe
biden say that he has a solution which
is to wear a mask he actually signed an
executive order
that anyone who enters federal property
right if you use
cross border transportation if you move
between states
anything that that the federal
government has a hand in you must wear a
mask
and this this will solve covid again i'm
not an anti-mass guy right i wear a mask
people in my office wear masks i think
it's a good idea but this is not a
solution here's joe biden saying no no
but i'm not allowed to say that here he
is wear a mouse guys just wear a mask
one of our 100-day challenges is asking
the american people
to mask up for the first hundred days
the next 99 days
the mass could become a partisan issue
unfortunately
but it's a patriotic act but for a few
months to wear a mask
no vaccines the fact is that they're the
single best thing we can do
they're even more important than the
vaccines because they take time to work
i mean and that's that's true i mean we
should be wearing mass and we should be
socially distancing until we can get
people
the vaccines that they need there's only
one problem which is that joe biden
immediately
upon being inaugurated started walking
around federal property without a mask
he wasn't wearing a mask now to a normal
journalist that might seem like a
question
but we know that asking those sorts of
questions are completely unnecessary now
because this is the most honest and
transparent administration we have ever
seen
we knew this from the moment they were
ushered into ushered into power
so peter ducey of fox news he has the
temerity to marry that bastard
to ask jen saki this question you know
joe biden
says that he wants masks for everybody
in fact he put into law
an actual mass mandate on federal
property but um
joe biden wasn't wearing a mask on
federal property yesterday isn't that
sort of weird
here is peter ducey asking the question
and jen sackey is like
well here's that vaunted transparency
openness honesty
you know just that straight talk that we
can look forward to for four
he years celebrating an evening
of a historic day in our country
yesterday was a historic moment our
history he was
inaugurated as president of the united
states he was surrounded by his family
we take a number of precautions but i
don't think
i think we have big bigger issues to to
worry about at this moment in time
okay can you imagine for just one second
if kaylee mackinnan gave that same exact
answer
it was a historic day he was celebrating
with his family do you think that that
would
that would wash for one iota of one
second
okay all we heard throughout the trump
administration was that
if donald trump was in a room with a
bunch of other people who had been
tested
if he was out there with his family and
he wasn't wearing a mask why won't he
mask up
but don't by the way i didn't realize
that there was an exception in federal
law
for the federal property mass mandate
for historic ceremonies
didn't realize that was a thing you know
how many people have not been able to
hold weddings during this pandemic
because it's a pandemic you know how
many people have not been able to hold
funerals for their loved ones
that seems by the way a lot more
important than joe biden celebrating
himself
i like just to be honest with you you
honoring your grandmother who died
you honoring a friend or family member
who died by going to a funeral that
seems like on a raw level
more important both emotionally and
psychologically than joe biden getting
to have that triumphant walk without
wearing the mask
but jen sackey says it and so it is so
so much transparency
so much honesty wow just incredible that
was only the beginning
by the way okay this it gets a lot worse
we're gonna get to this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that when you're running
a business hr issues can absolutely kill
you wrongful termination suits and
minimum wage requirements and labor
regulations
hr manager salaries are not cheap
they're an average of 70 000 bucks a
year bambi is spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month with bambi
you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone
email or real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day-to-day all
for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time
on hr compliance no you did not let
bambi help get your free
hr audit today head on over to bambi.com
shapiro right now schedule that free hr
audit that is b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro bam to the bee dot com slash
april again
if you're not covering hr you are going
to pay the price somewhere down the line
or
pretty fast the reality is one hr issue
can take down your entire company you
need to protect yourself
this is why you should check out my
friends at bambi.com shapiro to schedule
your
free hr audit okay so you might say to
yourself okay well yeah joe biden not
wearing a mask on federal property not
such a big deal i mean
it's kind of a big deal i mean like
gavin newsom going and eating at the
french laundry while having
a restaurant mandate and violating the
restaurant mandate like that that was
kind of a big deal and joe biden
saying like his first thing is everybody
needs to wear a mask and then
immediately stripping off the mask and
then the excuses it was historic
ceremony
a little bit of it but you know what in
the broad scheme of things it's really
more about hypocrisy than it is about
like a big deal
with regard to lying about policy for
example well
what if they also lied about policy so
the the biden administration
has spent the first 48 hours of its
existence
explaining that there is no plan for
distribution
none that the vaccines that have been
shot into the arms of several million
americans at this point right we are
shooting into the arms
of about a million americans a day this
vaccine apparently there was no plan
at all there was no plan at all so nancy
pelosi said this yesterday
trump had no plan for distribution none
which is incredible i mean without a
plan the man was able to
ramp up vaccine distribution to a
million a day my goodness if he had a
plan how great would that be
here's nancy pelosi spilling out this
lie yesterday
we learned this morning that the trump
administration had no real
plan for the production and distribution
of the vaccine
just another in a series of their
terrible ineffective approach
to it from the start in denial
delay distortion calling it a hoax
and now we find that they don't they
didn't
even have a plan okay so this was the
biden line right the biden
administration line the democratic line
is there's no plan
for vaccine distribution it just does
not exist and the media dutifully report
this
cnn reported it according to grabian
some 47 times yesterday
47 times they mentioned the idea that
there was sheer chaos in the vaccine
distribution now
can you make the vaccine distribution
plan better sure why not but the idea
that there was no plan
as it turns out is just overtly false
doesn't matter the media
you know buying that transparency from
biden they're just gonna they're just
gonna repeat this crap even though it's
not true
i mean really not true okay here's nbc's
kristen walker saying they are starting
from scratch i mean it's just chaos over
here
what you're seeing now is this
acknowledgement you're absolutely right
by zeinstein other top officials here
who are saying look the trump
administration
did not leave us with any working plan
to rule out this vaccine so yes we are
starting
from scratch but i think that what fauci
was saying and we'll have to press him
on this today when we get to ask him
some questions
is that at least now we're looking in
the mirror and acknowledging
okay we need to start from scratch
here's what a plan
will look like okay what if i told you
that anthony faucey the greatest of all
doctors who has ever lived
i mean in terms of ranking doctors it
basically goes like this
it goes like dr jonas salk
it goes dr j doctor strange
and then dr fauci's like way above all
of them doctor dr fouch is the greatest
doctor who's ever lived let me just put
that out there the man is just an
unbelievably good doctor
like if if anyone ever has a medical
problem called dr fauci he's
unbelievable anyway
he's a godlike figure we should all
light votive candles too
i was informed of this over the course
of the last year well what if i told you
that anthony fauci
said from the white house podium
yesterday that they are not starting
from scratch
and yet the media repeated the lie
because it sets the expectation that
anything that biden does is a success
because they are just stenographers for
the biden administration here's anthony
fauci overtly
contradicting the administration that he
now works for
we certainly are not starting from
scratch because there is activity going
on in the distribution
but if you look at the plan that the
president has put forth
about the things that he is going to do
namely get community vaccine centers up
get pharmacies more involved where
appropriate
get the defense production act involved
not only
perhaps with getting more vaccine but
even the things you need
to get a good vaccine program for
example
needles and syringes that might be more
useful in that
so it's taking what's going on but
amplifying it in a big way wait so it
sounds like they're not starting from
scratch
actually that's exactly what it sounds
like they're not starting from scratch
it doesn't matter
the media reported ad nauseum yesterday
that they were starting from scratch why
because jeffrey sense
who's the the obama coveted policy
adviser said this
say the biden coveted policy advisor
said this to the to the press the press
immediately just reported it as though
it was fact and then there's voucher
just completely undercutting them
but don't worry you're pressed doing an
amazing job holding people's feet to the
fire
what if i told you that they were also
fibbing about their goals
so the biden administration says we have
big plans here big plans a hundred
million vaccinations within the next
hundred days
and people who don't know anything are
like wow that sounds
unbelievable unbelievable you mean a
million
shots a day what if i told you that
we're already basically giving people a
million shots today
and kind of were when biden took office
and so he's not fundamentally changing
anything
so here is jen sackey being super honest
and super transparent by telling you
that it is an enormous
enormous increase in the number of
vaccinations being provided for job to
provide basically the same number of
vaccinations we're already providing on
a daily basis
here's jen sackey super honest super
transparent amazing stuff here
the trump administration was given 36
million doses
when they were in office for 38 days
they administered a total of about 17
million shots that's about
less than 500 000 shots a day what we
are proposing is to double that
to about one million uh shots per day
and we we have uh outlined this goal and
objective
in coordination and consultation with
our health and medical experts so
it is uh ambitious it's something that
we feel is bold
and was called that certainly at the
time oh it was called bold at the time
yeah by members of your stenographer
media okay this is how you lie with
stats
okay what she's doing there is lying
with statistics here is how it works
what she says is that the trump
administration was providing about on
average on average over the past 40 days
about half a million shots a day
now you said yourself well that probably
means that they were like every day
putting out half a million shots right
no that is not what that means it means
that they ramped up the vaccine
distribution
okay you can't take the average and then
suggest that that's actually what's
happening on a daily basis
that is like saying that bill gates for
the first 20 years of his life earned
zero money
and then bill gates over the next 20
years of his life
let's say that he made a hundred million
dollars over the next 20 years of his
life
that means that over the first 40 years
of his life he averaged half that
right so that means that when he was 12
years old he was probably making
you know like 10 million bucks a year or
5 million bucks a year no that is not
how that works
when you average numbers but there is an
escalating number that is actually the
year on year or day on day number what
you want to look at in terms of are you
ramping it up is the last day before you
took
office okay you don't get to do the well
you know on average here's what it was
that doesn't make any sense at all it
makes zero
sense okay but she just throws that out
there like oh well so they were doing
half a million now we're doing a million
we're doubling it now you're not
doubling it the day before you took
office
there were almost a million shots
administered you're taking office you're
promising to administer a million shots
which means you are escalating it by
like
close to zero everybody recognizes this
and this is not in dispute so instead
what you have to do is you have to lie
to the press and the press will
dutifully just report that out
in fact when reporter asked biden about
this when a reporter said oh by the way
we're already doing like a million
vaccinations a day
by just snapped at the reporter because
why
how dare he i've been told that if you
snap the press
if you get mad at the press if you treat
the press badly this is a fundamental
assault on our most basic institutions
impeach like what what it's uh how
how will our press survive jim acosta is
is under assault quick get jim to the
safe room
because the reporter asked biden a good
question but didn't want to answer the
question
and he got mad at the reporter so much
transparency
it's a new day in washington gang here
is uh here's joe biden getting mad at a
reporter for asking a perfectly obvious
question
thank you guys is that china far higher
that's basically where the u.s is right
now
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break
that's the question good start nope
no one said it was not possible when you
announced it literally zero people who
knew anything said it was not possible
when you announced it in fact
virtually everybody who knew anything
said when you said 100 100 million
vaccinations in 100 days
they said uh shouldn't be higher than
that like that's not ramping anything up
okay but again we all have to pretend
along so transparent
so honest so much media-ing
every time they ask a tough question
within the first 48 hours every time a
tough question is asked they just dodge
it or lie about it
and then the media are like but they're
so honest and they're so transparent and
they're so amazing oh my god
just unbelievable anyway another example
the very first night
the very first night of the biden white
house jen sackey did oppressor
and she was asked about joe biden's
policy with regards to the hyde
amendment the height amendment is a
federal amendment that says
that you are not allowed to use federal
taxpayer dollars to fund abortion
and she said we have no position on that
but joe biden is a good catholic and as
we know catholics are pro-life
okay within 24 hours anthony fauci had
announced the return of the mexico city
policy which uses federal taxpayer
dollars in order to sponsor abortion
overseas
so was that dishonest was that avoiding
the question
no no it's transparency and honesty guy
it's a new day the adults are back in
charge now the reality is it's not about
the adults being back in charge or any
realistic standard of honesty and
decency
what this is is that there's a complete
sympotico between the journalists and
the people they're covering right now
it's just confirmation bias they like
the people they're covering they didn't
use to like the people they are covering
they don't care if the people they're
covering right now
lie to them and fib to them and put out
propaganda talking points that is fine
with them because they like those
propaganda talking points
okay this is not about them holding any
consistent standard
it's about them holding a wildly
inconsistent standard it's not
listen they would be saying the adults
are back in the room if
it had been marco rubio who was
president it has nothing to do with the
adults being back in the room
all this has to do with is they agree
with the people who are lying to them
and so they're going to just cover for
them
they did this all throughout the obama
administration members of the obama
administration overtly admitted to lying
to the press and the press
kept licking their feet it was
unbelievable
and now it will just be more of the same
it'll just be more of the same
in a second i'm gonna get to some more
terrible terrible
coveted policies there are a couple of
policies that are now being trotted out
that are pretty amazing
plus a story that um
should receive more media attention but
likely will not
we'll explain in a second first let us
talk about the reality which is that
this year you've probably been thinking
dark thoughts and that means
that you need to think about what
happens in case god forbid something
should happen to you
that means getting life insurance if
getting life insurance is on your to-do
list for 2021
policy genius can help you cross it off
with ease policy genius makes it easy
for you to compare more than 30 top
insurers at once
and save over 50 in the process plus
there is no hassle because their
licensed experts work for you
not the insurance companies here's how
it works first head on over to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day you might even be eligible to skip
that in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they'll take care of everything that
kind of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating across over 1 600
reviews
on trustpilot and google so make this
the year you finally cross life
insurance off your list
get protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com
and get started you could save 50 or
more by comparing quotes
start the new year with one less thing
to worry about policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and
important to get it right okay so
there's another story that has been
making the rounds and the media are like
i can't believe this is happening but
who is to blame he said here is the
story remember how 15 000
american troops were sent to washington
dc to protect against the possibility of
another january 6th and then no one
showed up
in fact all across the country the only
violence that was done was done by
antifa in portland and seattle
who were attacking again government
buildings
or it didn't happen because antifa is an
ideology i forget which
i mean according to joe biden antifa
doesn't exist okay in any case
what happened to the national guardsmen
according to politico
thousands of national guardsmen were
allowed back into the capitol on
thursday night
hours after u.s capitol police officials
ordered them to vacate the facility
sending them outdoors or to nearby
parking garages
after two weeks pulling security duty
after the deadly ride on january 6th
one unit which had been resting in the
dirksen senate office building was
abruptly told to vacate the facility on
thursday according to one guardsman
the group was forced to rest in a nearby
parking garage without internet
reception with just one electrical
outlet
and one bathroom with two stalls for 5
000 troops
the person said temperatures in
washington were in the low 40s by
nightfall
the guardsmen said yesterday dozens of
senators and congressmen walked down our
lines taking photos shaking our hands
thanking us for our service within 24
hours they had no further use for us and
banished us to the corner of the parking
garage
we feel incredibly betrayed all the
national guard troops were told to
vacate the capital and nearby
congressional buildings on thursday and
set up mobile command centers
outside where nearby hospitals another
guard has been confirmed they were told
to take their rest breaks during 12-hour
shifts outside and in parking garages
the person said
top lawmakers from both parties took to
twitter to decry the decision and call
for answers after politico first
reported the news
senate majority leader chuck schumer
tweeted if this is true it's outrageous
i will get to the bottom of this
senator tom cotton noted the capital
complex remains close to members of the
public so there is plenty of room for
troops to take a break in them
a guard source confirmed late thursday
all the troops in the parking garages
were ordered to return
to the capitol brigadier general janine
burkhead the guards inauguration task
force commander confirmed in a statement
to politico a little after midnight the
troops are out of the garage and now
back
in the capitol building and they will
take their breaks in our emancipation
hall going forward
in a statement capital police
spokesperson eva malecki told the
department recently
they said the department recently asked
the truce shifts be reduced from 12
hours to eight in order to allow for
additional rest hours away
from the capitol complex it did not
explain why guardsmen were forced
into parking garages now you will notice
that nowhere in this piece does it
explain
who exactly is in charge here well let
me give you a hint
who's in charge here the president of
the united states is currently named joe
biden not donald trump
the senate majority leader is currently
named chuck schumer not mitch mcconnell
the house speaker is named nancy pelosi
not kevin mccarthy
so who is to blame you know what the
headlines would be if trump were still
president aren't you
donald trump forces forces troops to
sleep in parking garage
in 40 degree weather sharing but one
toilet for 5 000 people
you know that would be the headline but
here it's like oh how did this happen
how i don't understand what could have
happened here
amazing how as soon as something bad
happened under the trump administration
it was like
every republican we see in like a four
mile radius is to blame for this when
democrats are in charge and something
bad happens like
how could such a bad thing happen in
america how
who wha i'm not even gonna speculate as
to who is in charge
amazing by the way speaking of bad covet
policies so
my favorite thing is when democrats
claim that they are driven by the
science okay so here is dc's new
standards so washington dc has set a new
standard for vaccinations now
this should be very easy the center for
vaccinations should be if you're 65
you get one right we do it by age that's
how you should do it
if you are some if you are a doctor who
is working routinely with covered
patients you should probably also get
one
we should not be vaccinating people who
work in grocery stores or people who are
delivering packages at the same rates
that we are
vaccinating people who are 65 and older
right it should be an age based decision
end of story so what is washington dc
doing being driven by the science
entirely democratic area how are they
actually tranching out the vaccines
according to the washington post the
district plans to give priority
for coronas coronavirus vaccines to the
broadest possible swath of people with
pre-existing health conditions
a decision that will make hundreds of
thousands eligible for scarce doses of
the vaccine and that some public health
experts say
might not make medical sense might not
make medical sense here's what they're
actually proposing
okay you ready for this the plan would
offer vaccines to people whose weight
and medical history would not qualify
them for early access to the vaccine in
almost any state
in the country apparently d.c health
director laquandra nesbitt
told members of the dc council last week
she decided to open up vaccine access
possibly as soon as february to such a
large group in the hopes of quickly
vaccinating anyone
so who what what exactly is the um is
the cutoff the cutoff is
you just have to testify that you have
any pre-existing condition
at all right you just put it on your
form you just say that you're
a smoker or you've had cancer or heart
failure or diabetes or down syndrome
okay these are all chronic conditions or
or
you have to have a body mass index over
25.
okay just to be clear a body mass index
over 25 is like everyone
okay unless you're in pretty good shape
you do not have a body mass index under
okay that just means overweight
overweight is 25 obesity is 30.
i'm in pretty good shape i work out
pretty much every day my body mass index
is like
22. okay so the the the bizarre notion
that you're going to tranch out hundreds
of thousands of vaccines to anyone who
is slightly overweight
as opposed to you know the the people
who are elderly and at risk total
craziness but of course the goal here
is racial equity above all right that is
the goal here
experts like david cass a johns hopkins
cardiology professor
said some of the conditions the district
is including have not been proved to put
people at higher risk of complications
from coven 19 the disease caused by the
novel coronavirus in terms of body
weight some recommended prioritizing
people with bmis over 40
rather than anyone whose weight is above
a level considered healthy
i mean bmi over 40 is severe obesity bmi
over 30 is some risk
there's no evidence that bmi of 25 is
gonna kill you
okay but again bad policy doesn't matter
all that matters is the wokeness the
wokeness is what matters above all
okay well you may be looking at the
state of modern american politics and
you may be saying to yourself you know
what
these media i hope they finally get the
message that they actually need to be
watch dogs right
that was their job the objective media
they need to be watch dogs they can't
just be lap dogs they need to be watch
dogs
and the american people actually get it
so there's a pull out
from edelman it shows that the american
trust in the media is at an all-time low
as well it should be we shared with
axios here is what the poll found
apparently the trust in traditional
media 46
of americans say they trust traditional
media presumably they are all democrats
among republicans those numbers are
abysmal only 18
of republicans say they believe
journalists after the 2020 election
which
i mean hard to argue with that not sure
why you would
the vast majority of members of the
american public believe that journalists
and reporters are purposely trying to
mislead them
and 58 think news organizations are more
interested in ideology than facts
57 percent of democrats trust the media
shocker
shocker i can't believe it you mean you
trust the media because they tell you
exactly what you want to hear all the
time but don't worry there's no leftist
bias
in the media
apparently republican trust in
traditional media plunged following the
2020 election
but the truth is that that plunge should
have happened much earlier
the the republican belief in the
veracity of the media
it found a 15-point drop in media trust
among trump's trump supporters
apparently about 33 percent of
republicans used to trust the media now
it's only about 18
i'm not sure why anyone trusts the media
to simply be objective they simply are
not
they are not objective in any way shape
or form
and and the proof is in the pudding i
mean every single day i show you clips
of members of your esteemed journalistic
media
who are basically just doing dirty work
for the biden administration or for the
democrats or for the biden campaign
during the campaign
so for example here is cnn's allison
camarada literally asking members of the
biden administration
if they will retaliate against news
networks if they lie
so will here's cnn asking if the biden
administration is going to target
newsmax oann
and fox news yeah definitely i trust cnn
absolutely objective people
no no interest here they are just truth
tellers
by the way that is unconstitutional okay
the the biden administration has no
power to involve itself in in
these particular debates here's allison
cameron are pushing it anyway
i heard that as a direct shot at some of
the media companies
that lied about the election results
we know who they are i mean they're
they're you know right-wing companies
some are more fringe than others at this
point
or more i guess extreme than others and
so if they continue
to engage in lies something that he is
trying to combat
what is your communication strategy will
you
deny those networks any interviews i
mean
what happens if they re revert to form
immediately
so will you punish will you revert to
form will you tell people that you won't
interview with them
because cnn doesn't like them please
will you do that i mean we are the truth
tellers here at cnn everybody else on
the other side those are not true
tellers
at all cnn is the place you come for
your news and also
for your for your kool-aid from the left
side of the aisle
okay so the the funniest example of this
over the past 24 hours i i thought this
was hilarious so there's a piece here's
the title of the piece it's by margaret
sullivan margaret sullivan is the media
columnist
for the washington post and she has a
piece
that is titled i kid you not the media
can be glad for the biden white house's
return to normalcy
but let's not be lulled you know if i
just read you the title
you would think presumably that the
piece is going to say to the media yes
this is more of a return to normalcy
it's not quite as wild and crazy as the
trump years it's not all about the
tweets
but you still have to be watchdogs right
what do you think that's what i mean
that's the title of the piece right the
media can be glad for the biden white
house's return to normalcy
but let's not be lulled wrong
margaret sullivan says let's not be
lulled
let's not be lulled into covering them
with a harsh glare
right i i have to read it to you because
it is just so indicative of the mindset
of the media
the media believe they were too hard on
obama too hard on hillary
that's why they got trump and the lesson
of the trump years is not that you
should be aggressive with the white
house in power
the lesson of the trump years is that
you should only be aggressive with
people you disagree with politically
that is what margaret sullivan the media
columnist for the washington post writes
here's here's her take on it you ready
white house press secretary jen sackey
was prepared
she was professional she was
non-combative and she didn't peddle a
whopper of the y
the way sean spicer did on day one four
years ago with his alternative facts
about the supposedly record-breaking
size
of the inaugural crowd the first
official words by president biden's
spokeswoman included truth
and transparency rebuilding trust with
the american people will be central to
our focus
the former state department spokeswoman
told a small group of socially distant
reporters
as she promised to return to daily
briefings in fact
wednesday night's session with reporters
the first of the biden administration
was so normal
so weirdly normal that you could be
forgiven for thinking you had mistakenly
put on an old episode of the west wing
my favorite thing about that is that she
is touting the west wing
as like the way politics should work it
was a fantasy show written by aaron
sorkin on behalf of democrats
like but that's the way the reality i
wish the reality were just the western
yes i'm sure you do
i'm sure you do the return to norms is
wonderfully welcome after the horrors
of the past four years it's like running
into a friend you haven't seen in four
years wrote columbia university
journalism professor william gruskin
okay so here's where you think that the
article is going to turn right because
here's what she says it's also
potentially dangerous
okay now here is where you think it's
going to make the term here's where you
think she's going to say yes it's a
return to normal
but we can't be lulled into a false
sense of security we still have to hold
people in power accountable
nope nope that is not what she is going
to say
she is going to say the opposite here we
go
the national press battered by four
years of abuse by the president and by
the incompetence and falsehoods of his
spokespeople is in a precarious position
position
we run the risk of being seduced by an
administration that in many people's
in many cases closely reflects our
values multiculturalism a belief in the
principles of liberal democracy a kind
of wonky idealism so she's openly
admitting by the way that the media and
biden are the same right and she says
the commentary from tv broadcasters
across the board all day long
was at times embarrassingly
complimentary maybe that's fine for a
day or two while everyone takes a few
sighs of relief that democracy has
survived its stress
test but soon i'd guess another normal
return the desire to appear combative
and to blow things out of proportion to
demonstrate toughness
she's chiding the media before they do
it
with being too combative with biden
after they basically provided him sexual
favors on the day of the inauguration
that's what margaret sullivan is doing
here she says you know what
you guys we spent the last 48 hours
celebrating with biden
and treating biden with kid gloves and
you know we have to be really careful
here
not to stop treating them with kid
gloves
because journalists pride themselves as
margaret sullivan media columnist for
the washington post
on being tough and objective they like
to take an adversarial seeming approach
especially to the party in power or the
candidate with whom they most identify
and of course actually holding power to
account is the most important job
journalists have
it's what we're here for but there's a
difference between truly holding power
to account
and grandstanding it's the latter that
gave rise to ridiculous dustups like the
one over president barack obama's
wearing of a tan suit
not to mention the vast and shameful
overplaying of the hillary clinton email
scandal during the 2016 campaign
the national media says margaret
sullivan should show toughness but of a
different sort
if they've learned the lessons of the
past four years and i confess i have my
doubts they'll do things differently
they will resist false equivalency for
example
they'll think twice before they put a
reality denying senator like ted cruz or
josh halley on the air
they will clearly call out lies they
will identify racism or white supremacy
by using plain language instead of
euphemism
it's just it's amazing it's just amazing
so the media
have gone into full-blown
full-blown best little whorehouse in
texas mode and margaret sullivan is like
yes but
but could we add some services on top of
that to really make sure that we are
doing our job here you know
the last thing we need is for you to
even pretend to do your job the real
problem here is you're probably going to
start going soft on republicans that's
probably the big problem here
so let's go harder on republicans and
let's not cover any of the things that
by
i mean like do you know how in the
bubble you have to be to believe this
these folks have decided before
beforehand in preordained fashion the
biden administration is
transparent wonderful factual and the
biggest risk
is that you will create a false
equivalency between people who disagree
with biden and biden because of course
we all know on an objective level that
biden is wonderful
and amazing and truly spectacular
they're just they're just fanboys they
should just write fan scenes
everything the media write these days
and i think honestly since the obama era
everything that they write is
essentially just in touch magazine
about these folks it's incredible it's
incredible
and meanwhile i look forward to a return
of non-comedy
we'll get to that in just one second
remember that time that comedians were
funny
yeah and me neither it's been a while
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that if your
sleep quality has been lacking that is
because you have a mattress you bought
at a store didn't you i know what you
did you went to the store you lay down a
mattress for like five seconds
like oh this is probably fine and now
you've been lying on that lumpy mattress
for the last 10 years you need a
mattress that is made for you this is
why you need a helix sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting all
these unboxing videos from so many of
you who also found the helix mattress of
your dream so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
you're matched to the mattress comes
right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
by both gq and wired magazine just head
on over to helix sleep.com
ben take their two minutes sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you have to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll pick it up free if you don't
love it you will helix is offering up to
200 bucks off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com it's an amazing deal
again check them out at helixsleep.com
to get the kind of mattress i sleep on
namely one that is made just for you
alrighty it is that glorious
time of the week when i give a shout out
to a daily ware member today it is john
galt on twitter we finally found out who
he is
he values good entertainment in the pick
the world's greatest beverage vessel is
in a cozy living room with our own daily
wire god king up on the flat screen the
caption reads
the only way to watch the real daily
wire premiere of run hide fight is
crawled up with my pup
munching on skinny pop washing it down
with the thirst quenching tears of
hollywood
hashtag leftist years tumblr hashtag
take back the culture awesome
run hide fight is a great movie we hope
you enjoyed it thanks for the pic thanks
for being a daily wire member if you
haven't heard about it yet
of course daily wear is now in the
entertainment game last week
we released our first film run hide
fight exclusively for daily wire members
you can catch it over at dailywire.com
on the mobile app on our streaming apps
at apple tv and roku and if you're not a
daily buyer member yet use
promo code rhf that's run hide fight rhf
to get 25
off to watch it the credit score is
currently at 30 the audience score is
now at 93 percent
that's the kind of entertainment we're
gonna make the stuff that you guys love
and the critics probably hate
reviewers are very angry at the movie
reviewers are very very upset
at the movie well who cares the audience
loves it
it was made for you again the movie is a
great thriller it follows zoe
a high school student trying to get
through the last few weeks of her senior
year when her high school is attacked by
school shooters using her wits and
survival skills zoe fights back to save
her fellow students we are excited to
bring you amazing stories hollywood
refuses to tell we hope you'll join us
and become a member today over at
dailywire.com remember you get 25
off when you use promo code rhf go watch
the movie
if you like it leave a review you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so obviously we are hoping for
a return to comedy at some point in the
future here's the problem
it really wasn't trump that killed
comedy it really was obama who killed
comedy
as soon as barack obama was elected in
2008 and took office in 2009 the media
declared that he was off-limits
our comedy specialist decided that
comedying was over i mean you literally
couldn't make fun of him there was
nothing funny about barack obama now
on a purely objective level that is just
not true barack obama was
hilarious he was hilarious i mean the
man thought that he was just a
messianic figure descended from the
heavens to teach all of us
about what it meant to be the best kind
of human and the media agreed with him
it was really funny like on an objective
level
barack obama god like figure going over
22 on the basketball court kind of funny
okay like barack obama jetting off
in the middle of crisis to go hang out
with celebrities kind of funny
there's a lot that was funny that was
going on during the obama administration
but not to comedians because they were
too busy worshiping and you can't make
fun of things that you worship right
it's very difficult for people to do
that
and religious people tend not to mock
their gods
okay and and these folks are religious
well then it became okay well
we won't actually mock trump we're just
gonna yell at him they were so angry
at trump that they couldn't even be
funny about trump it was mostly just
he's a very bad man it was like a
sputtering rage that came from the
comedians well now we're gonna revert
back to
the obama years except it's gonna be joe
biden so joe biden who is legitimately
one of the funniest people to ever be
president of the united states not
because he means to be funny but because
he cannot spew
four sentences without mixing himself up
and walking into a wall
like that's funny okay they were able to
make fun of gerald ford one of the most
athletic presidents in american history
for being
kind of doddering but joe biden who's 78
years old cannot string together a
coherent thought
that's not funny at all it's not funny
at all in fact
what we need from our comedians most of
all is to be the priests
of the new woke religion and that is
what they do
so here we have stephen colbert stephen
colbert
explaining this is what comedians do now
they explain to us how much they cry
comedy's over gang it's dead it ain't
coming back
not under these conditions there is no
such thing as a is a comedy
routine that exists in the world of
wokeness because everything is just
to puritan here is stephen colbert being
hilarious by explaining how much he
cried
when joe biden won the presidency by the
way stephen colbert's life was so rough
under donald trump i mean all he did was
leap to the top of the ratings despite
being utterly unfunny
and making a bajillion dollars what what
a rough life he had under trump i mean
every day he was under threat of making
more money
it was really really difficult for
stephen colbert but now stephen colbert
he's weeping tears of joy
weeping tears of joy listen when donald
trump beat hillary clinton i didn't weep
tears of joy i laughed my ass off it was
really funny
okay there's tape of me doing it and
there's
like it has several million views of me
just laughing hysterically because
that's
really really funny okay stephen colbert
hasn't laughed in several years and it
shows
instead we must cry along with him he is
by the way he's on the cover of like
vanity fair holding a dove or something
this month yeah our comedy specialists
are no longer in the business of comedy
here's a here's a non-comedian an
ex-comedian
the inauguration was a joyful occasion
like i do at most happy things i cried a
lot
it was true
it was extremely emotional and not
entirely
in the way that i expected because i
have to tell you i have zero
gloat in me there is no end zone dance
here what i feel
is enormous relief watching the
inauguration today
i recognize just how worried i've been
for my country
wow oh oh no he wasn't being funny
i can't i honestly can't tell the
difference i cannot tell the difference
in when he is trying to be funny when
he's not trying to be funny
also another person who used to be funny
but now is just a woke pope jimmy kimmel
right he he emerged wearing his uh his
black non-turtleneck his long-sleeve
black shirt here
to to explain to all of us that you know
this it's it's like a magical magical
day now this is actually supposed to be
a funny line but i'm wondering
how like where is the where how okay
here's jimmy kimmel explain the humor
joseph rapunzel biden is our 46th
president
it feels like i have to imagine this is
what it feels like when the oncologist
calls and tells you the tumor is benign
you know i remember going back to the
day trump was inaugurated
such a a terrible day and wondering
can our country even survive four years
of this
and now we know the answer not really
just barely but we made it mar-a-lardo
left town bright and early this morning
so oh my god well the the quality of
that writing
i mean those are the kind of jokes that
are only surpassed
by the jokes that you find on the handle
of the popsicle stick
that's pretty much it well done i i will
say that that the last 12 years have
killed comedy
they have killed objective journalism
there's not a lot left in terms of our
institutions
and our fun and everything seems like
sort of a bland gray
going on from here does it not it is
just it is just
boredom and annoyance stamping on the on
the american face forever
that is that is the future of the
country oh yeah and also bad policy
so ezra klein has now moved over to the
new york times after turning vox
into a place that ostracizes everybody
of dissenting views so bad that matthew
iglesias had to leave
and found his own sub stack now ezra
klein has been rewarded with a slot over
at the new york times
where he has a podcast and also he has
an opinion piece because the new york
times
like no one who has voted for trump will
ever be allowed to write for the new
york times like ever ever ever again
it's not going to happen
the most right-wing person at the new
york times right now is ross dowthat
and that's because he's sort of
iconoclastic and because he is
not super trumpy but he's also kind of
in favor of
man i like ross's column but ross is not
easy to pin
down in in sort of traditional
conservative ways
okay the the the other columnists are
like the most right-wing columnist after
that
is brett stevens who hates trump with a
with a fiery passion of a thousand sons
right
so you've got ezra klein over at the new
york times here is his
pitch for what democrats should do next
remember this is the era of unity it's
the time of good feelings right
so ezra klein's pitch is let's kill the
filibuster and just ram through a bunch
of crap
let's do it let's do it ezra klein says
that what we need is we need a massive
spending bill
we need a 1.9 trillion dollar rescue
plan that biden is pushing
we need a for the people act which is a
wild rewriting of how voting is done in
the united states
we need a revision of immigration but
says has reclined none of these bills
will pass a senate in which the
filibuster forces 60 vote majorities
on routine legislation that clarifies
the real question democrats face
they have plenty of ideas that could
improve people's lives and strengthen
democracy but they have repeatedly
proven themselves more committed to
preserving the status quo of the
political system then fulfilling their
promises to voters wait hold up a second
let me just read that let me read that
sentence one more time
because if you think that it's just
authoritarians on the right who are the
threat
let me read that sentence to you one
more time remember we were told that the
threat of authoritarians is people who
care more about outcome than they do
about the norms
about the institutions of our democracy
right
that was the entire pitch here's ezra
klein in the pages of the new york times
remember
well-intentioned good-hearted liberal
ezra
here it is i'm going to read it slowly
so you understand what he's saying
democrats have repeatedly proven
themselves more committed
to preserving the status quo of the
political system than fulfilling
their promises to voters they have
preferred the false peace of decorum
to the true progress of democracy there
it is
our institutions must be raised and
democrats must push forward all the
things as raquel likes
otherwise you know they might lose
elections and we wouldn't want that to
happen
if they choose that path again they will
lose their majority in 2022 and they
will deserve it break
all of the institutions of democracy in
order to save democracy guys
i mean where have i heard that before
wherever i heard that before oh yeah
from every authoritarian ever
all we have to do is just overrun all
the institutions and we can do all the
things you want us to do
very very exciting stuff it by the way
is how that perspective is how we got to
this idiotic form of government that we
currently experience
in which basically all that government
is is congress has a vestigial organ
that occasionally passes omnibus
packages worth trillions of dollars
and mostly government is just president
ping-ponging back and forth executive
orders
obama does a bunch of executive orders
then trump undoes the executive orders
then biden redoes the executive orders
then whoever comes next undoes those
executive orders
but ezra klein wants to break the wheel
of history the way we're going to break
the wheel
is not by returning power to the
legislature in its current form and
minimizing the power of the executive
instead what it's going to be is we're
going to kill the filibuster
we're going to ram through things on a
bare majority basis
and then everybody's going to be better
we'll maximize power in the federal
government probably that will bring
everybody together
oh goody gumdrops yes the era of unity
has begun you feeling unified
are you arya are you yeah didn't think
so okay we'll be back here later today
with one additional hour of the ben
shapiro show in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
that is available right now apparently a
republican congressperson has filed
articles of impeachment against biden
on the first day in office michael we'll
tell you all about it on today's
show in the meantime have a great
weekend i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wydowski our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your
way through the fall of the republic
with me andrew clavin